they lined up for hours tens of
thousands of people
queues stretching for blocks
all here to see the president's official
residence
we are so excited because this is the
only chance us to go inside
so we are so proud of
ourselves
we are looking for the new president
for the better prospect for our country
mass protests forced the president
guterbaya rajapaksa to flee
and now those protesters are in charge
of the mansion
it's become the city's number one
tourist attraction
this is the president's bedroom next
door a vast marble bathroom
bigger than the entire homes of most sri
lankans
but no visitors are allowed in here
why do you want to protect the
president's house
we need to protect this public property
and we need to protect the people too
because people thousands of people are
coming to watch it and if the people
gather here in thousands this flow
cannot hold it and if something happens
every life matters for us
from the personal gym to the pool
sri lankans are taking it all in
trying to get their head around the
opulent lifestyle of the ruling elite
in a country where people can't afford
to eat the sight of the president's
private swimming pool in the most
exclusive address in the country only
reinforces to sri lankans the great
divide here between rich and poor
and while families pack into this
people's palace sri lanka grows poorer
it's run out of money to import food
fuel and medicine
this stately home is a world away from
the daily indignities people are
suffering from in the middle of this
economic crisis
for now the people are being allowed to
stay
waiting for their president and prime
minister to formally resign
these are unpredictable days for sri
lanka
nicole johnston sky news colombo